un hebdomadaire britannique annonce une
fécondation sans spermatozoïdes ce
serait le produit entre guillemets d'une
manipulation plutôt hasardeuse conduite
par un biologiste parisien l'explication
jean daniel flaysakier
alors j'en ai nous allons voir ses
explications très pratique de cette
manipulation faite par un un biologiste
parisien en quoi at elle constitué valu
le principe si vous voulez c'est que la
dame nature mais 74 ou à fabriquer un
spermatozoïde et là bas et c'est un
phénomène compliqué naturel très long
parce que il faut plein de choses se
mettent en place qu'est ce qui s'est
passé dans ce cas là et il y en a on
appris chez des hommes stériles chez qui
la le développement se produit mal on a
pris 10 il bloqué à un stade très
précoce et on les a mis en une sorte de
soude hormones de façon à arriver en 48
heures a fait à faire ce que la nature
fait en plusieurs dizaines de jours
alors on va le voir en images expliqué
parce que c'est peut-être un petit peu
compliqué à appréhender on fait un
spermatozoïde la nature met du temps
entre la cellule souche de départ dans
le testicule et produits finis il va s'y
coller 74 jours mais il ya des hommes
chez lesquels le processus ce blog
presque au départ et sont donc stérile
une équipe de biologistes européen a
décidé de court-circuiter la nature ils
ont pris une de ces cellules bloqué
l'ont plongé pendant 48 heures dans un
plein d'hormones et obtenu un précurseur
du spermatozoïde ce qu'on appelle une
espère mathide ronde injectés dans un
ovule elle a permis à une femme
d'accoucher de jours le taux de réussite
est très faible à peine 10% et cette
méthode qui accélère des phénomènes
naturels de façon importante pose
beaucoup de questions la technique assez
compliqué les résultats imprévisibles
on a quelques cas seront donc il faut
peut être attendre d'autres résultats
pour pouvoir en dire plus il vous êtes
inquiet optimiste quand vous développer
des techniques comme ça je suis un
dingue est optimiste mais beaucoup de
scientifiques se 10e franchement étiez
alors inquiétudes et ses hasardeuse je
disais tout à l'heure un oui parce que
depuis quelques temps on voit fleurir
ces méthodes de procréation assistée un
peu bizarre qui sont elles aussi très
hasardeux ou salée car en dehors de la
méthode naturelle que je ne vous
réexpliquer pas ici il ya 23 700 de
faire des enfants même trois façons
aujourd'hui une véritable explosion des
techniques de biologie ce qui fait que
c'est qu'il ya une offre considérable et
l'autre côté il ya une demande aussi
considérable parce que les couples qui
avaient un désir d'enfant maintenant
pour pense plutôt en termes de dos
l'enfant les biologistes leur montre
qu'on peut tous faire qu'on peut a
priori guérir théoriquement toutes les
stérilités et ben pourquoi pas y avoir
droit soit aussi le problème c'est qu'on
utilise maintenant des méthodes à toute
vitesse qu'on ne prend pas le temps de
les évaluer qui a beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent en jeu on est plus en commerce
et dans le marché que dans la science et
qu'on s'aperçoit à ces derniers temps
parce qu'une des méthodes favorite né il
ya quelques années et qui a permis
plusieurs milliers grossesse elle permet
de mettre au monde des enfants dont un
certain nombre ne serait peut-être pas
en très très bien sur tous les plans le
problème c'est qu'on se rend compte
maintenant une fois que les enfants sont
arrivés il aurait été beaucoup plus
intelligent peut-être de prendre le
temps de mesurer ce qu'on faisait et de
s'apercevoir qu'on peut voir des
anomalies avant que ses enfants naissent
et aujourd'hui c'est devenu une
véritable folie et beaucoup de pays
notamment des pays du golfe sont prêts à
payer des fortunes pour acheter ces
scientifiques comme on achète des
footballeurs pour aller développer ces
méthodes chez eux ainsi jean daniel